this is a production of Cornell
University
I think the previous speakers take nice
overview of how animal science and plant
science have you know work together and
some of the concepts from one one field
were used in another field so so this
this this cross-disciplinary learning
was was really important in driving the
plant breeding and as well as animal
breeding in the past I'll give you a
some personal example of how this
cross-disciplinary learning have helped
us answer some of the complex questions
in field phenotyping this is an example
from our lab so he started in 2014 with
the UAV if you know typing a project I
joined Jesse program in genetics 14 and
right about that time we were starting
to explore UAV phenotyping and how we
can use this phenotyping in breeding so
we record involved in that project we
had engineering people people from
engineering department Kevin Wong he was
a postdoc in bio engineering a deal in
stock use of chemical engineer so he
started a UAV testing program so we
started a flying UAVs testing new new
platforms to see how with which which of
the platform fits well with the with our
goals we did a lot of testing and
crashing to but good thing is it was a
cheap UAV so we could afford so the arms
and legs were like very cheap so we
could replace them so a lot of learning
in 2014 and then 2015 we had people from
geography and by informatics joining in
and really helped us move ahead with the
with the with the learning some other
things for example we narrow down to
sensors what kind of senses we can use
and
so we picked one or two sensors that
were really working well with our with
our program and we made a lot of
progress in analyzing this data
2016 we had a a VA ssin engineer joining
our team and he was he really helped us
collect a lot of data in the field and
really ease my work because I was doing
a lot of flights and I the genetics was
which is my core field I totally was
behind so he really helped them so then
I started focusing on the genetics and
using some of these datasets generated
using these new to new platforms and
sensors so this is really to highlight
how cross-disciplinary teams can can
really bring in new learning in the and
how we can we can use this this T's
approaches to to answer some of the
complex questions so so ultimately like
this cross-disciplinary approach and all
these things so our main goal in in
Plant Sciences and Sciences is to
connect you know you know so but it's
it's a very crucial link if you want to
improve so but we also have to address
this shield phenotype important like at
the same time and high-throughput
phenotyping
can really help us to understand this
genotype phenotype link this STP can
allow us to rapidly and accurately
measure trades and in this specially in
the field which is really a bottleneck
so we can we can test a large number of
plots and field which can really help us
study these complex traits similar
traits which are really hard to measure
and I will give you an example today for
lodging
so a little bit of what we were doing it
we are doing in the in the in the lab
and some of the studies that came out
from our lab we had a few studies
showing how this new STP tools can be
used in large breeding nurseries really
one of the cool things cool thing about
UAV phenotyping is that we can you this
trade in a dynamic dynamic way because
we can we can measure this phenotyping
you can you can take these measurements
of measurements multiple times during
the season and that allows us to look at
the trait in a dynamic way we can you
can really see how things change over
time in season so rather than just
looking at a single point we can think
of it as a dynamic and imma trade and
this is an example so so UAS for
audience assessment in wheat this is
this is what I'll be talking about
mostly so lodging this is how it looks
from the sky
the drone I can see that just unaffected
by lodging so so we we so we thought
initially like when we saw this these
images I was collecting data regularly
for for hi-8 and NDB I other things then
I saw these images and then I Jesse and
I talked and we thought can we quantify
this lodging using these this image
based approaches so just a little bit of
background lodging is a permanent
displacement of plant stem from its
upright position it can have a severe
impact on yield and yield and quality in
wheat but loading assessment and field
is very laborious and it's subjective in
nature
so this limits our population size for
genetic studies so this limits how how
many plots we can we can we can study in
the field so that was really the driving
force for us to use high-throughput
genotyping so that we
we can really address this this issue
so the the study objective was really to
to develop us-based lodging assessment
approach so ready to see how we can use
these image based approaches to quantify
a lodging at the field scale and then
also to to come up with the proof proof
of concept how we can use this this
these phenotypes they be image based
assessments to study the genetic
architecture of lodging so our field
setup was so these are heap trials
symmetry in trials in India we had this
experiment going on in the field I
basically I was already taking data as I
mentioned so I what I did was I
basically picked two dates free lodging
date and the post lodging day and
created generated a digital elevation
model from be straight these dates in
both here so we had a close to 600
entries in both years so and also at the
same time I collected ground truth data
just to compare how how how these image
based approaches that I'm going to test
on do compared to the two the visual
measurements so so the the approach that
I used was based on digital elevation
models I took a pre lodging digital
elevation model subtracted from post
lodging digital elevation model so
really to get a differential TEM which
is a change in elevation over time so
these two time points and then use this
differential diem in each plot to really
come up with two different indices one
is a very simple index which I call
differential lodging mean or DL mean or
digital logic mean so this is basically
just taking the average of all the
differential points with
applaud that that's first index second
index is a DL mixture I call this is a
based on a more informed a normal
mixture distribution based index so
little bit of how the DL mix is
calculated so basically we have
distinguish this an example from single
plot so we have a two normal
distributions one corresponds to the non
launched part and another one is a large
part of the part so we basically
estimated the parameters of each
distribution and came up with a came up
with a lodging index multiplying that
these two parameters from the large part
of the distribution so now I have two
digital lodging indices and three ground
truth measurements so I took lodging
incidence which is a which is a severity
zero to understand lodging sorry this is
the incidence and severity is on a scale
of zero to ten how how much of the plot
is so the first one is how much of the
plot is the Lord area is loyd second one
is how severe is the lodging on the
scale of zero to ten so then I also
combined lodging index and and lodging
severity to see how this compares so we
explored phenotypic relationships on the
diagonal you can see the first three are
the visual traits visual assessments of
lodging this the last two are the DL
mean and DL mix and the in the
parentheses these are the broad sense
heritability
so this is 2016
we had comparable heritability z' broad
sensitivities and very high correlations
correlations among visual and the
digital assessments of lodging so so our
ma
space assessments were working at this
point I also looked into the genetic
correlations so genetic correlations
were also very high in both years above
0.9 so which was really good so so we
were so we were we had evidence that
what we are measuring is actually
lodging and they were measuring the same
variation so once we had this these
validation results we wanted to look at
into the genetic architecture and see
how we can use some of these approaches
and understanding the key genetic
architecture of lodging so in 2016 this
is a Manhattan plot from 2016 first year
there were no significant market rate
associations in 2017 however there was a
peak at from some to a this peak
correspondent to translocation segment
which is a translocation segment from a
jalops went to cosa which is a while
ancestral meet this 2ns segment is
involved in a lot of it has been
extensively used in in breeding programs
historically because it has a lot of
resistance genes
this peak was was really consistent
across all measures of lodging so that
was a good thing to see but an
interesting thing was that the restock
markers only explained up to two percent
of the variation so the variation was
was very low the variation explained by
these these markers was really low
suggesting that this could be a really
complex trade and trade with a diffuse
architecture with large number of small
effective low side so to explore that
hypothesis of diffuse architecture we
generated a k-fold genomic predictions
so we wanted to look how if we can
explain some of this unexplained
variation through genomic whole genome
prediction models so here is a
comparison in two years 2016 and 2017
there's a prediction accuracy and then
prediction accuracy scaled to the square
root of heritability to see how to show
how the the proportion of proportion of
heritability netic variation that is
explained by the prediction accuracies
so we were able to explain up to 53
percent of be the the digit heritable
genetic variation which was really nice
to see and we also tested it across
environments so crossing model
prediction accuracies were also high
here we are comparing the prediction
accuracy of phenotypic correlations and
genetic correlations so this so data
from luciana location where I collected
UAV drone data I used as a training set
to predict lodging at another location
in Pakistan so they had lodging in the
index values that they they they
collected in the field so I was able to
compare it across environments also and
the results were also encouraging across
environments so we were
so this was another validation of and
another proof of how how we can use some
of these these UAV based credits to to
to look into the genetics of for complex
traits and then we were also wondering
if we can establish a relationship of
lodging with with the economic trade one
of the interesting things we saw was the
correlation of lodging with with grain
yield so in 2016 so this is a result
from 2016 was coalition was negative the
relationship is is opposite so you have
higher lodging lower yields 2017 however
was different the relationship quarter
worst so you have lines that are high
yielding they are more prone to logic
lodging so either of these cases can
happen in the field right so some years
you can have lodging at that stage where
we're lodging happens earlier and then
it leads to two yield losses in other
cases you have lodging with lodging when
a crop is is already headed and it's you
know heavy and then the so it makes the
the high leaving plant more lodging
proven so that was interesting to see so
just quickly the take-home point time so
so hopefully I provided some evidence of
the scalable assessment of lodging on
thousands of field plots so we were able
to do that in the field this field based
high-throughput phenotyping can be used
to study complex traits and plants we
have that so not only just study we have
other examples from other studies we
have we can use some of these new tools
to
tools to study the complex traits and
feed genomic predictions can adequately
explain the heritable genetic variation
the complex traits traits with complex
genetic architecture digital lodging can
be integrated with current reading and
prediction pipelines a lot of reading
programs have started using this UAV
based approaches so so these approaches
so so having a new new trait you know
from this study they can easily use this
easily incorporate this these new tools
into their breeding programs UAV
programs can really benefit from from
the predictions and so finally thanks to
my advisor Jesse Poland at Kansas State
University we have a great team at
Poland lab then we have collaborate
great collaborators Borlaug Institute
for South Asia in India CIMMYT Mexico
has been a good big support
Robby Singh's program on read we have
cement Pakistan our collaborator
Mohammed in India's so they were great
asset and our funding agencies thank you
[Applause]
thank you I was terrific um we open it
up to questions now how far off of the
centerline of those plots did you have
to fly in order to get that height that
height measurement when you're flying
directly over you can't see the height
right no yeah so when we are so when we
plan our flight we have a 7080 percent
overlap between the images so we make
sure that we have this 7080 percent side
and forward overlap so basically using
this this overlap we can create a 3d
model so we have 3d points so that's how
we could leap it better so this this
height was was extracted using the Z
value so you have X Y and then with the
3d model you can have a Z value the Z
value is your height so basically it's a
you can do height and enlarges lodging
is an extension of height so in terms of
the you know did it large because it was
super weak and that'll be loading or
because it was too powerful for its own
good and I mean so how many time points
do you have the did you do the fire
doesn't have a digital elevation models
for like how many times a year did you
do the flyover that was that you could
get the digital elevation models just
once okay so if you did it at like three
time points you would yeah actually I
have more time points so you mean like
different days yeah if you did it once
early in the season and late in the
season itself which one right so the
thing is like sometimes your plots they
get up and then so so the these points
were chosen based on when I took the
visual observations so the visual field
observations so I just picked those two
dates but if you look at the temporal
like different days you can see
sometimes the plots can get up right it
just really may be like if this is
something that that can be notches
yeah yeah so so it can't be like it's
not always like hundred percent but you
know if it's on the scale of one to ten
ten being like fully lost you can come
back to like seven or six or something
so the change is like with with time so
maybe yeah we can we can map that
trade-off see ya do we have any
questions on the zoom we can see thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu